all right we should be live
um
so here we go first
welcome thanks for joining us in this
live edition
of the stronger by science podcast i'm
your host your one and only permanent
host eric trexler but i am joined today
by a special temporary guest co-host his
name is greg knuckles greg thanks for
joining me yeah yeah thanks for having
me on you might be wondering why i
invited greg to be a guest co-host for
this specific episode and it's because
we're going to be talking
about our diet app that we work together
on uh with a team of people that we're
really excited about today is obviously
the big day we launched it today so this
is part podcast uh part celebration part
infomercial um
so thanks for joining us for the
celebration here greg
i want to begin
with a question
do you know why may 19th is a
significant date
um
not right off the top of my head
on
the 19th of may
in the year 2019
you and i in a way in many ways in most
ways
change the world okay because we looked
around and we said
podcasts
exist but no one has done it in fitness
yet yes and so that was the first date
we released an episode
created the first and only fitness
podcast and brought that into the space
and of course there have been copycats
since
uh
similarly we recently were looking
around and said
phone applications exist but why has no
one tried to do a nutrition focused app
it really is shocking you would think
there would be one by now you would
think and so
much like we did with the podcast we
said let's change it and today
we release as far as i know the first
and only diet app which we're really
proud of the first the only and still
the best yeah so
we're going to talk a little bit about
the app we're going to answer some
questions stuff like that but i think
first a good question would be
why build
a diet app so
i don't know greg
why build a diet app
man
i was having a really hard time scraping
together funds for my fourth home and so
uh
just put another another product out
into the world no um
yeah why do it so honestly the best
the best person to answer this question
and and this is uh
i guess kind of the story of our of our
founding of macro factors founding
is uh back in 20
2015 i guess i don't know it's a long
time ago and i'm old
uh yeah around 2015 or so we put out a
spreadsheet
that
[Music]
was basically
the core
sort of logic of the app but very dumb
um
so very simple
yeah it could have been better yeah um
so anyway uh corey one of our developers
had been using the app for a while or
had been using the spreadsheet for a
while i mean um
and had basically uh enjoyed it overall
but saw some key ways that it could get
better uh and said like hey if i
developed this thing into an app uh
would you have any interest in
partnering you know given feedback
releasing this thing on your platforms
uh going into this thing as partners
and i said uh
i don't know let's see uh
why don't you make a prototype uh so we
can get an idea
of whether this is good or not because i
people hit me up about stuff
on the internet all the time
um
and and most of very specific by the way
people hit you up about stuff on the
internet yeah exactly we've all been
there right guys on the world wide web
um
[Music]
a lot of people pitch
uh
seemingly enticing opportunities to to
me uh and then often times when you
drill down into them they're not all
that enticing uh so
i mean i didn't know the guy so i was
like yeah
make something come back to me like once
you have something to show me then we
can talk about it uh and so he went away
for a few months put together a very
basic uh
version one of the app i was like holy
[ __ ] this is actually pretty slick um
and so at that point we uh you know we
just we decided to move forward with it
so
um yeah i mean
why do it uh
corey would probably be the best person
to ask
uh but you know basically
we uh
we saw the work that he had done already
and uh
you know thought that there was real
potential to make something really
really good
yeah and i think you know we had had
discussions when we were looking at the
first version i think the biggest
question for us was you know is there
really room for improvement here can we
do something that we feel is better than
what's already available because
obviously i was being facetious there
are plenty of apps out there that can
give you
calorie recommendations macro
recommendations
uh facilitate with the logging of your
food and the tracking of your macros um
and after digging into the calculations
seeing the prototype you know it looked
like we could really really do something
cool and so that brings us to today and
it's kind of funny to think
if you can think back to when we first
saw
the initial version yeah and how much
changed from then to now it's kind of
funny to think back to how blown away we
were at the first at the first instance
but
anyway um
you know our ambition with this i mean
if you've been following stronger by
science content and the stuff we do in
mass and things like that
you're probably aware that greg and i
like messing around with math and
numbers that's generally a fun thing for
us and so our ambition here is to really
create a solid solid diet app with
really precise estimates and we want to
continue
adding complexity to the algorithm as we
go as we gain more and more information
and so we put a ton of work into
developing
what we've launched today we're stoked
about it but the long-term trajectory is
to continue digging in to these numbers
as we go which is going to be a really
exciting thing
and of course along the way we
absolutely plan to roll out more and
more features and continue you know the
user experience based on the feedback
we've been getting in alpha testing beta
testing is great but we want to continue
improving that as we go as well you know
constantly getting better and that
brings me to the next thing which is you
know you mentioned corey um you know
we're good at a couple things not many
but certainly not development of phone
applications correct uh i would be
completely worthless and
my understanding is that you can't make
a top-tier
either ios or android app and r so no
you can't that that would uh
be a problem for you well if you can i
can't um
so that brings me to point number two
which is just kind of introducing who we
are and when i say we i'm talking about
macro factor
um
and you know we teamed up with corey and
rebecca our our developers and then
obviously
um you know has been doing all sorts of
crazy stuff prepping for the launch um
so so that's that's the core team here
and what we're really excited about is
that it truly is a team you know we're
all co-equal partners we all have skin
in the game and we're really stoked
about the fact that our
our development team
literally lives
in the city we live in um like they are
part of this business 100
like they're literally downstairs right
now you know like so one of the reasons
we're excited about that is because you
know a lot of people who work in the app
space
they outsource a lot of their
development to uh contractors it can
lead to
slower fixes when there are bugs it can
lead to friction in the process there
can be continuity issues where you just
kind of hand over an app to a contractor
who's never seen it and they're like i
can figure out how this works and try to
tweak it yeah um but you know this is
really a team here and we're really
excited about that because
you know
first of all it's a great team like we
we love the people involved but but we
we really want to make sure that we uh
are responsive to our users and continue
to roll out really good features as we
go yeah uh so i see some people in chat
asking us to to bring them up and get
them on the podcast we asked them uh if
they would be interested in appearing
and they said and this is a direct quote
uh we were watching chat your last
episode and uh a lot of those people who
who watch your podcast are a bunch of
dicks so uh
maybe not so anyway um
they will probably come on at some point
but uh the fact that they're not now uh
that's on you guys so absolutely shame
on you and uh try to do better but no so
um
yeah this is
this is maybe the thing that i'm the
most passionate about when it comes to
the long-term uh
like the long-term strength of macro
factor compared to other um
other like diet nutrition diet coaching
apps on the market
uh
and this is something that like you
can't put it on a sales page it's not
like a feature that
would maybe like resonate with someone
who's just coming across the app but the
thing that excites me the most is just
how [ __ ] good cory and rebecca are
um
it's it's truly stunning so the the app
as it is now they've been working on it
for a little bit over a year
and i think
i mean i'm clearly biased here i think
it's the best
app on the market uh it it does in its
current state
still have
some drawbacks there's still some areas
that
could use some improvement in polish uh
but i think that you know feature for
feature function for function uh it goes
toe to toe with anything else that's out
there and they've it this is two people
working on it part-time for a [ __ ]
year and that's compared to other apps
that have been on the market for a
decade and have development teams of
you know it for some of the larger apps
20 plus people um
and so
what they've already been able to make
is
absolutely incredible
and the fact that they've been able to
make it in a year blows my mind uh since
alpha testing started like six months
ago i think they've put out like
somewhere around 30 builds of the app
yeah which uh i mean there are nutrition
apps on the app store that haven't had
30 total releases in their lifetime
uh and some of those were bug fixes but
a lot of those were rolling out major
new features um
and so
we're not going to talk about this type
of stuff on this episode of the podcast
but we have
we have some big plans for
where macro factor is going to be headed
and and things we want to do with it in
the future
and i
i have uh
intense and abiding faith in our
developers um
[Music]
to a degree that is perhaps unhealthy
but jesus christ they are so [ __ ]
good um and
you know when you guys
check out macro factor i think you're
going to be very impressed uh because
like i said it already goes toe-to-toe
with anything else in the market after
just one year of development and as good
as it is now it is going to get so much
better because they are so good
yeah and that brings me to you know the
other part of who we are as macro factor
that involves the user base as well i
mean we've got great developers
but uh we really want to foster a true
community of users and we want to lean
on user feedback so that we can continue
to adjust things and roll out new
features
that are really prioritized by the
people who have skin in the game the
people that are actually using this app
on a day-to-day basis so
that is who we are as macro factor i did
see a question in here asking if the app
could give people super powers and i
would basically defer
to my tercestrone answer again and say
we have no evidence to say it will but
also technically no evidence to say it
won't so that is correct pretty
interesting when you think about that
were there any user questions that
jumped out to you before we start like
eventually we're going to talk through
some of the features that are most
important to us i think but did you see
anything uh you wanted to comment on
here
uh just in terms of like chat scrolling
by yeah yeah um
did you see something i can i can look
real quick
answer something i i did see one person
well first of all mike lane uh the good
doctor mike lane i thought mike lane
might be here because i saw a lot of
eastern kentucky university students in
the chat so he
i believe he told his students they
would get extra credit if uh if we
answered their questions
um
but uh so
something
there's only if we answer them
uh i don't know so that there are a
bunch of kind of just generalized
fitness questions from
from dr lane's students
by the way dr lane was uh
very perturbed when he heard you say
that research should just take the form
of dissertation projects uh he he as
someone who had completed a dissertation
he
got some pretty severe flashbacks from
that and wasn't pleased so
you'll have to take that up with him
you know one thing that somebody
commented on here not necessarily a
question
uh well two things first of all someone
asked about alcohol being handled within
the app
and you know within the app you have
running totals of your macros you have
running total of your calories that are
being tracked we do track alcohol as
well yeah and so we don't have to like
lump it into a different macro or
anything like that it gets tracked
independently and that's one of the
things that i really like about the app
is some of the extra stuff that can get
tracked you know like
um
a lot of times some of the some of the
apps will do you know the basic macros
maybe fiber maybe some key
micronutrients
and of course i haven't tried every diet
app out there but you know with ours
we've got you know alcohol caffeine
water fiber starch sugars
net carbs if you're into it
i like the fact that you can look at
specific amino acids um different fat
breakdowns including omega-3 and omega-6
so uh the the short version of the
answer is that alcohol is tracked uh and
as long as you're logging foods that
contain all the necessary information
that stuff will get tracked so if you're
using uh foods you know within the
database that have full information and
we use a really good database by the way
uh all that stuff will get tracked and
that's been interesting me uh as i
continue to eat more and more
plant-based proteins because i'm not
eating meat at the moment
it's been nice to kind of look through
some of the amino acids and make sure
i've got my bases covered
another comment in here was about
um
what was the comment oh about the app
being adherence neutral that's what i
was going to comment on yeah you can
take the lead so this is your this is
your show this is your world it is
living in it absolutely my show and it's
important that
viewers and listeners don't forget that
you know
uh so being adherence neutral is
something that we're stoked about
because uh
adhering to a diet is hard for
many many reasons i think it's pretty
self-evident and you know there are some
diet apps that'll say hey
we'll continue to update and give you
new calorie recommendations and new
macro recommendations and things like
that but only if you're always perfect
uh which is uh
probably not ideal in the real world
yeah you know so um the logic behind our
app the way that the actual calculations
and estimates work
do not rely on you being perfectly
adherent to your macro targets of course
that is the goal is to be pretty
adherent to get pretty close to your
targets um but but we don't require it
um and
having poor adherence does not alter the
app's ability to make accurate
estimations you know so that's one of
the things we're stoked about because we
want the app to be you know we call it a
diet sidekick more so than a diet coach
it's because we want the app to be a
resource for people whether they're
trying to
lose weight gain weight maintain weight
or track other factors of their diet you
know there's more to it than just weight
change um you know we want to make sure
that it's a tool that people can use
that doesn't require them
to be totally
fixated on the numbers and with a level
of precision that's just going to drive
them crazy so
okay
i'm a little sleep deprived so
maybe my judgment isn't
its best and i'm getting a little heated
so i might be about to get myself in
trouble but i'll well we are live and
the last time you did this i didn't like
it so anyway go ahead anyway we'll
we'll see
um
but yeah i know so uh
like eric was talking about the the app
and the calorie updates week to week are
adherents neutral so you
uh you track your weight every day you
track your nutrition
and you know you say you want to we you
want to lose
or gain weight at a particular rate okay
how much should you beat
so i
fully don't understand
uh
why
adherence would matter
so the the kernel of this app like i
said was the spreadsheet that i made way
way back in the day
and
uh that was based on like some very very
basic physiological principles so
you know if you
uh
if you know the rate at which your
weight is changing and you have
reasonable estimates of the caloric
content of the weight you're gaining or
losing you can then estimate uh how
large of a deficit or surplus you're in
if you know
rate of weight change and nutrition
intake so like
if you have those three things rate of
change
weight and
nutrition intake
you can you can estimate someone's
daily energy needs uh the biggest
drawback of the spreadsheet was
basically just that it didn't
take into account enough data and didn't
smooth the the data well enough uh which
are two major things that the app uh
corrects and addresses
but i
fully don't understand why
just for generating
recommendations
why adherence should even enter the
discussion um
because the
the basic principles of physiology are
the same regardless uh you know if if
your daily calorie needs are say 3 000
calories and you're trying to lose a
pound a week and you roughly need to eat
2 500 calories a day and you eat 2 500
calories a day and you lose a pound a
week bada bing bada boom it's working
well if you eat 2 750 calories per day
you're somewhat non-adherent you lose
half a pound a week well okay that's
still useful [ __ ] information i know
i know that the original recommendation
was correct you didn't stick to it so
you didn't lose as much weight as you
wanted to but it still contains the
information needed in this case to not
make an adjustment yeah on the other
hand if you ate 27.50 and you lost a
pound a week on that then that says that
like oh that's useful information the
initial estimate was too low i thought
you needed to eat 2500 per day to to
meet your goals it's actually 27.50
i don't see why
you wouldn't be able to update
recommendations based on that
information that you're acquiring uh so
yeah like making our
algorithms and recommendations adherence
neutral
it's not like that was hard to do and
it's it's not like we had to sacrifice
anything to get there uh to me
it seemed like the only logical way to
do it yeah
yeah so it's a really nice thing because
um you know people
aren't going to be perfectly adherent
and it's important that the app
continues to still function well and and
deliver and give good estimates so we're
really stoked about that um did you see
anything that you wanted to comment on
in the uh the chat here uh that was the
biggest uh serious question i wanted to
comment on
uh someone asked what my thoughts on on
harry potter were interesting um we
should we should dig into that
all magic is devil magic uh
the
story of king saul bears that out so
yeah i think uh i think that should be
pretty clear also uh this is not solely
just going to be a sales pitch so i want
to answer uh another question just so
yeah just so this this doesn't fully
become a billy mays late night
infomercial um those those were good
though
they were uh rest in peace to a legend
but uh let let's get uh
let's get someone from kentucky a little
bit of extra credit i'm gonna start with
joe here uh greg could you share your
thoughts on buffalo binching
useful does it help with a certain
muscle for example chest more
if someone just wants to be strong and
doesn't power lift would you recommend
it um
so yeah binching with a slight cambered
bar
i think it's good
it increases range of motion buffalo
bars duff low bars they have a
relatively gentle bend to them
so for most people it should still be
pretty tolerable for your shoulders um
i'm personally a huge fan of a mcdonald
bar like a three inch just straight up
bench press style cambered bar for those
reasons you can you can bench through a
longer range of motion uh
if you are not as short-armed and
barrel-chested as i am that
that bar might uh
expect
shoulder range of motion that you just
don't have
um
but i i think uh buffalo or duff low bar
is is a pretty good compromise for most
folks but on the flip side going the
other way if you're someone who has
you know a
relatively thin torso uh front to back
and really long arms
you know
just a barbell bench press itself to
your chest might be a pretty challenging
range of motion and so
uh
it might be a little bit risky to try to
bench through a longer range of motion
and you probably certainly don't need to
bench through a longer range of motion
so yeah i would say for most people on
average the slight increase in range of
motion from a buffalo or duflow bar
probably has a
small net salutatory effect
on training responses especially for
your pecs but uh
yeah i mean the the range of motion you
binge through if you're dealing with
specialty bars tailor that based on your
your relative arm length uh and the
degree to which binge to your chest is
is uh accomplishing what you want it to
accomplish
yeah good stuff you know there's another
uh question that
is related to
what the diet app does but isn't
specifically about it so this is from
eku
um
did i lose it
oh no because if i don't mention the
name they won't get the extra credit it
was about calories in yeah
so uh that last one was from joe i don't
know if i said that joe from eastern
kentucky university all right so i've
got one from uh tyler smith over at
eastern kentucky uh is calories inverse
calories out the perfect formula for
weight loss or weight gain is there a
missing factor that we haven't
discovered yet um
you know i think probably the best
answer to that is contained within a
series of articles that you just put up
on the website you know so
um do you want to briefly
summarize what those articles indicate
basically they walk you through because
yeah you hear about it the articles
themselves are summaries like yeah yeah
it would be
it would be hard to summarize them
further yeah so you can check them out
the two most recent uh stronger by
science articles good to check out i
would say um
two things though
one is that uh
one is that i i do think that there is a
not major but
non-trivial factor that is that is often
unaccounted for and that's uh energy
lost via fecal mass
so um or
you know not just via fecal mass but via
energetic macro nutrients that make it
all the way through your digestive
system that you excrete uh so i i used
to think that outside of disease states
the amount of net metabolizable energy
contained within feces was like truly
trivial like you know less than one
percent of what you ate
i came across a review paper recently
that suggested that uh even for healthy
non-diseased individuals a typical range
is like two to ten percent of the
calories you consume
and i mean you know if we're accounting
for thermic effect of food in metabolic
calculations you know when you're
dealing with something that might
account for up to 10 of total energy
intake uh that's that's a non-trivial
factor so
um
one thing to keep in mind is if you want
to be really
like a huge stickler for this stuff uh
technically
technically and this is a huge
technically this is the type of thing
where if you break it out in common
conversation when someone talks about
calories and calories out they'll
probably punch you in the face and
honestly you'll deserve it
but if you wanted to be super technical
about it calories in doesn't really
start until food is actually absorbed
because your entire digestive tract um
is is like sort of outside your body if
that makes sense so the human body is
kind of a donut
there is a hole that goes from your
mouth to your anus that is continuous uh
you could pass a string through
your entire digestive tract without ever
puncturing a tissue it is fully
continuous with the outside world
so technically
calories in starts
once
energetic nutrients are absorbed and
make it through uh
the lining of your your small and large
intestine um so technically uh energy
law lost via uh fecal excretion
that doesn't necessarily impact that
that impacts the calories in part uh of
the calories and calories out equation
not the calories out part
because technically those calories
never fully go in in the first place
um and the other thing that i think
and and we talked about this on our last
q a i'm pretty sure so i'm not going to
get into it too much
um but i i think it's important to note
that um
that oftentimes when people
think that there's like a paradox that
quote unquote breaks the calories and
calories out paradigm oftentimes it's
just a matter of not adequately
accounting for the calories out side of
the equation um so last time around we
we talked about kind of the dead zone
that you can have in in terms of a range
of calories where body weight doesn't
change very much because you can have
various adaptations changes in need
changes in maybe basal metabolism to
some degree
etc etc
um
and so yeah i think that a lot of the
confusion stems from the idea that like
oh hey if i
reduce my calorie intake by
200 calories per day i'm going to start
gradually losing weight and you know
maybe your weight doesn't change at all
that doesn't mean that the calories and
calories out equation is is broken um it
just means that you're doing a pretty
good job of accounting for calories in
and a pretty bad job of accounting for
calories out which isn't on you uh it's
it's really hard to account for calories
out um but yeah oftentimes that's what
confusion comes down to it's just uh
very
not easy but it's relatively simple to
quantify one of those variables and
quite challenging to quantify the other
one
yeah i mean there was a a post that that
we made on instagram
a long time ago several several several
months
that was about calories and calories out
and uh you think about that phrase
calories in calories out it sounds like
you basically have two terms to take
care of
um but the post was about a paper by
kevin hall who's uh kind of like that
one of the lead nutrition researchers at
the national institute of health
and he does a lot of really good work in
nutrition
and he also does a lot of modeling work
and so he had a paper modeling body
composite composition changes in
response to various interventions
and if you opened if you were so unlucky
as to open the appendix or the
supplementary material with the actual
equations
it was like i think 64 or 66 equations
something like that yeah that were used
to approximately represent
the relationship of calories in calories
out you know and so it there's so much
more to it than
i exercised for this many calories i
think and i i'm pretty sure i ate that
many there's a lot to it so so yeah if
you ever feel really frustrated about
why the numbers aren't matching what
you're expecting a lot of times there's
quite a lot to account for there yeah
yeah
one thing i do want to clarify so
uh there's a question here about
plant-based diets
so uh james said i mentioned last time
that there would be an option to
auto-set calories and macros based on a
plant-based diet um but they didn't see
that in the program set up uh perhaps i
misunderstood the question last time
around but um you know
macro factor
uh the the diet app we're putting out
that we're launching today is fully
compatible with plant-based diets for
sure but there there's no mode where you
would say i'm on a plant-based diet how
much should i eat you know we would
basically
make recommendations the app would make
recommendations for your calorie intake
and your macro breakdown based on the
other factors you indicate you know
based on your goal your estimated energy
expenditure um your exercise habits your
exercise experience things like that
and so all these other demographic uh
features and uh calculations would go
into
you know what your calorie and macro
targets would be
whether you choose to hit those via
uh an omnivorous diet or a totally uh
you know
plant-based diet is really up to you uh
and you know
the only real accommodation some people
like to make is that they go a little
bit higher with their their protein
intake
the more applied research that comes out
i'm less convinced that that's totally
necessary if you have some pretty good
plant-based protein sources in your diet
and you're eating an appropriate amount
of protein
but if you wanted to do that when you go
through the setup of macro factor
one of the things we want to do is make
sure we account for preferences right so
as you're going through and you're
putting in all the information it says
what kind of protein target would you
prefer you know middle of the road would
you like to go super high with it so
if you were
on a totally plant-based diet and a
little bit concerned about that you
could simply just indicate a preference
for a higher protein recommendation i
don't think it's required or necessary
but if you wanted to you could do it
yeah so uh and again one of the things i
really like is being able to look at
those
those amino acids that's a pretty cool
feature for uh vegetarians and
especially for vegans as well
absolutely i've got
two uh two questions to to answer that
are related but may not seem like they
are uh so several people have asked
why isn't our app free why is macro
factor not free
and another person asked about data
privacy would we be selling your data
and uh yeah those two things are very
very intimately connected um
so
your your data privacy is uh is
excellent we're not going to do [ __ ]
with your data except for things we do
in-house um
virtually all of the data we collect
uh
and i say virtually all
because i'm not a hundred percent sure
about all of the app permissions we ask
for but i'm pretty sure it's all and if
if it's not all it's virtually all uh
the data that we're collecting what it's
for
is basically to improve our
uh
daily energy expenditure estimations
over time
um
because
like currently it works
really really well it works uh
i would say almost shockingly well uh
and you know that's
obviously we're trying to sell a product
here but that is a true statement from
me to you that's uh that's an honest
assessment of how well it how well it
works um but it all it already works
really well but there are a lot of
little things that we could maybe
account for better um like edge cases to
account for and you know we're talking
about the types of things that might
affect uh estimate precision
in the in the realm of like you know
maybe 50 calories per day or something
uh like the the core functionality is
excellent but
we're we're obsessive about numbers
so we want to improve it even more the
vast majority of the data we collect is
just so once we get users coming into
the app we'll be able to analyze it and
we can improve our algorithms um
and so how does that relate to the app
being free
basically or
to the app not being free to be clear um
so
if you're putting out a free nutrition
app uh that almost necessitates selling
data or
letting other people access the data in
some way shape or form largely in the
form of ads
so um
i mean ultimately
uh
like nutrition database apis aren't free
our estimated cost per user per month
just for
uh hits to the nutrition x api
uh or nutrition x api calls is probably
about
two bucks two two and a half bucks per
user per month give or take
um all of which is to say you know
that's that's not free um
and so okay if we wanted to put out a
free app uh and use some third-party
nutrition database api
uh how could we fund that well we could
sell subscriptions which is what we do
or you know we could we could put ads on
it
and if we put ads on it then ultimately
that means
you know you don't necessarily have to
sell user data to advertisers but uh
they're gonna they're gonna wanna be
able to run targeted ads based on
demographics and characteristics of your
user base so that's where a lot of uh
data privacy risks come from like if if
a product runs ads that's
um
you know that's something to be aware of
uh some of that data might be surfaced
to third-party individuals
so the fact that we do have a paid
product that means we don't have to run
ads which make sure that your data is
safer
um
i feel like i had one more thing that i
was going to add about that
anyway we're not doing anything with
your [ __ ] data
it's safe um
uh let's see
here's another one thing i i should
mention since you brought up the payment
model people have been asking where's
the link where do i find this um and
things like that
uh if you're interested in the app it is
in the what do they call it the google
play store yeah the play store and the
ios app store and the app store you can
also go to strongerbyscience.com
macro factor
and in terms of the pricing uh there is
a 14-day free trial
so if you want to check it out without
making that long-term commitment you
know 14 days for free
in terms of the subscriptions if you go
with the monthly it's 9.99 build every
month if you go with the
every six month kind of plan
it's 41.99 billed every six months ends
up being about 699 a month and if you go
with the yearly plan it's 59.99 billed
once per year uh which ends up being
about 4.99 a month and those are our
special uh sale prices that are only
available until september 30th yes so i
remember the other thing i was gonna say
uh the other option if you if you want
to not run ads but you also uh
want to have a free tier of the app
is basically uh to have a shitty free
version and then a really good paid
version and
uh one of the things that we believe in
is that everyone should have
as good of an experience as we can give
them on the app um so
one of the things that i
think a lot about and am concerned about
uh really in most aspects of life is
what are the incentives in a particular
situation uh and if
something seems like a good deal but you
look at the incentives and there's some
perverse incentives and i'm like
i don't know how i feel about this
so anyway um
if you have a free tier and a paid tier
and you know you basically use the paid
tier to finance the free tier
i'm not saying everyone does this but
what you're incentivized to do
is make the free tier good enough that
people aren't just going to delete it on
the spot but make sure it kind of sucks
enough that people are
adequately
incentivized to uh
to to pay for the premium
and
i just don't want to have to deal with
it with that calculus
um to see like how bad of a free app can
we get away with to to adequately
incentivize people to pay us um
i would just prefer for it to be good
for everyone so that that's the other
that's the other way that we could have
a free tier and that also just doesn't
appeal to me um and there was another
data related question from jordan
blevins uh how long is your data stored
forever
um
let's see so i i see rebecca is in the
chat
and if i'm wrong she can correct me but
uh your data
for the most part is just stored
for however long you want it to be
stored so if you cancel and you say hey
i don't want these people to have any of
my data anymore you can delete the app
and request your data deleted and we
will delete it all we will have none of
it anymore um
if you don't do that then i don't know
if it's forever but for a long long time
we will hold on to it so if you sign
back up at some point your prior account
will be there uh all of your prior food
preferences will be there all of your
old data will still be there um
so
basically if you
you know if you
trust us with your data which you should
we're not going to do anything with it
other than uh make our algorithms better
um
we'll hold on to it and if you come back
to the app it'll still be there uh or if
you just okay rebecca confirmed we do
hold on to it forever unless you request
to delete it but if you do request us to
delete it we will delete it and then it
is completely gone and we will have no
way to access it again so you have
complete control over your data
yeah good stuff
now
i kind of want to be efficient here
by answering many questions with one
answer
so one of the things that's come up
quite a few times in the chat
uh is questions about comparisons to
other apps so you know you do you do
this as well as that app or do you have
this feature that they have and also
things about pricing
compared to other apps and i think the
easiest way to answer that because
there's such a long list of potential
features
if you go to strongerbyscience.com
macro factor uh we made this huge grid
you know that and it shows basically our
app and several uh competitors that are
fairly similar products in terms of what
they try to do
and it basically goes through a bunch of
different features whether or not
different apps have it and then compares
the pricing as well so
if you're
asking those types of questions probably
the easiest way to get the information
you're looking for is by going to that
website
yes sir do you want to do you want to
get back into the outline for a little
bit sure yeah
let's see here what is up next
uh
ooh
features we're most excited about yes
what feature are you the most excited
about trex
uh
so
there's a lot here um
oh one thing i did want to mention that
i think is a cool feature
just briefly i want to acknowledge it so
uh
the developers corey and rebecca spent a
lot of time making sure that users are
going to have really a really seamless
experience you know as few clicks as
possible without losing an intuitive
feel
and you know one of the things that was
important to us from the start was kind
of a quick menu to do some very quick
tasks right
and so uh
they they really outdid themselves with
that because someone asked if there was
like a quick ad type of thing for foods
so we have a little quick menu that you
can open up by pressing like a little
plus button
and
you of course you can add foods very
quickly in a variety of different ways
but you can also adjust the menu in
terms of which icons you want to be
presented in that little quick menu and
in what order
i think that was a really cool thing
that users are going to appreciate once
they you know dive in and start
adjusting that
um but
in terms of things i'm excited about
there's one particular feature that
blew me away that i was really uh
shocked about
the ai described feature i think is the
coolest thing in the world
uh so
i'm a bit lazy with food like it's not
that i'm unable to enjoy it
i'm able to enjoy food but you know what
i get from food
uh
never is enough to
to convince me to do anything
time-consuming or effort-consuming or
burdensome or cumbersome so like i just
eat plain easy stuff because i'm like ah
who cares right so i'm always looking
for those shortcuts and the ai described
feature is pretty incredible you
basically hit a little microphone button
and
describe what you just consumed uh the
food
the amount the unit that you're using
and you can do multiple foods at once
and it will populate and basically say
like hey do you want to log all that
stuff you just said
like literally said using your voice and
then you say yes that would be great
it works shockingly shockingly well yeah
to me it wasn't that long ago
uh that that just voice to text
couldn't even tell what the [ __ ] you
were saying but
like a word processor yeah i feel like
hey
that part works flawlessly yeah and then
i would say uh
it pulls up the correct foods
based on the words you say
comfortably in excess of 90 of the time
yeah yeah so that that in my opinion is
one of the cooler features
um and like i said some of the other
stuff that gets tracked i'm pretty
excited about like i i used to use uh my
fitness pal a lot back in the day and
would sometimes be looking for a
particular nutrient and if it was being
tracked i didn't know where to find it
you know um but but i like the
micronutrient tracking the the amino
acid tracking things like that i think
are cool um what are the features that
you're most excited about so i i think
the one that is
one of the more basic features but also
probably the one that helps me the most
is the weight trending feature so i'm
someone who's
day-to-day body weight fluctuates a lot
like i don't know i don't know if i just
become super dehydrated from time to
time or
uber hydrated from time to time i
honestly have no idea what the [ __ ]
going on uh but my my body weight can
swing
like eight pounds within one week pretty
easily and pretty regularly um
and so
uh the the weight trending feature i
think gives me a lot of peace of mind
because it used to be
that if a diet was overall going pretty
well
uh but then i had say two days back to
back where my weight was up like six
pounds
i i would know this was irrational but
my little lizard brain would say like oh
[ __ ] your diet's going terribly uh
[ __ ] it why even try you know
um
and so i think the the peace of mind i
get just from that nice smooth weight
trend um
absolutely incredible it's
uh it seems like such a small thing but
it's been really really huge for for my
adherence and peace of mind i would say
um
and the other thing and honestly this
could just be a me feature i don't know
if
anyone else will interact with it the
same way i do but
um
one of the other things that's that's
helped me a lot
is i know
the logic that goes into the app right
so i i know how uh our total daily
energy expenditure estimate is
calculated and so i know where the
calorie recommendations are coming from
uh and it's it's purely logic driven and
deterministic and so i know that if i do
hit the recommendations or at least get
reasonably close to them i am going to
get the results i won which
currently is is losing weight um
and so yeah
like again
since other people
weren't the ones that made the
algorithms i don't i don't know if their
experience of that will be the same as
me um but that that's been huge for me
uh the other thing that's been awesome
uh one so one of the reasons probably
the biggest reason why
i haven't um
regularly tracked
nutrition intake very often in the past
is just that it would end up feeling
very cumbersome where
um you know
just you have to log one food at a time
it would take quite a while to do
and uh corey and rebecca have built in
so many little features into the food
log to
uh speed up the time that it takes to to
log something and it's the type of thing
that it sounds like it's going to be
small but
um
you know if your law if you put
something in your mouth five times a day
and the the interaction between yourself
and your application to log everything
and get it all squared away if that's
like
say a minute on another app versus often
times like [ __ ] 10 seconds on macro
factor
that
that reduction in friction has has made
it so much easier to track consistently
so one of the features of the app that i
think i probably use the most uh for the
food logger is smart history so that's a
good one so if you eat similar foods
around this the same time each day that
the app will remember that uh in your
history and so you know you go to add a
food and your smart history is there and
so you don't have to search anything if
it's if you're going to be eating
something that you commonly eat at that
time you just tap it log it bada bing
bada boom uh very very
seamless quick transaction uh and and so
i think just the
the slight reduction in friction
virtually every time i go to log
something uh has been so huge for for
continuing to stick with the the habit
of vlogging yeah a lot of people
who
do a lot of food locking food logging
they tend to have in many cases pretty
consistent dietary habits from day to
day and just you know some fluctuations
here and there
and so when you combine the smart
history which which you mentioned where
it's like dude you know what happens at
noon i know what you're about to eat and
it comes up front and centered that's
that's really useful but then there's
the copy paste functions as well um so
uh the copy paste function from day to
day
is super cool um and so
between those two things like the app is
going to get you to a situation where if
you have relatively consistent habits in
terms of your tracking it goes for your
intakes it goes from
extremely convenient tracking to like
stupidly convenient tracking yeah like
that that those features specifically
are are really really clutch
so
i'm gonna pitch an idea eric tell me if
you hate it okay we've been we've been
on here for about an hour uh
i promised some some fireside chat
content which we very much have not done
and i don't like being a liar cool and
also this has been pretty sales pitchy
so far
um
and i'm sorry greg we've been working
for a year and a half and i'm proud of
it so uh
there have been some
so i'm gonna be completely transparent
here there have been some some uh
tougher questions or more critical
feedback that's come up in the chat and
i don't want it to look like we're just
ducking those uh thus far the questions
we've picked have largely been ones that
that we could just really tee off on
yeah last time someone asked why we were
so handsome and we were happy to tackle
that one absolutely yeah so um
so yeah i think a good way to end this
episode uh
is to
go with a combination of fireside chat
questions and tough questions okay so i
am not going to scroll back through the
app or through the the chat i mean to
find things there's there's a lot of
chat and i don't read that fast
uh so if you have
fun non-fitness related off-topic
questions
or uh
challenging pieces of feedback or
challenging app questions that you know
you're not just uh teeing us up to make
a sales pitch throw those in the chat
now uh i i think that would be a good
and honest way uh to end this episode
yeah no there is one thing that i that i
saw in the chat that is easily addressed
so
the uh
there are many ways to log foods there's
the database um
and there is the ai described you can
search the database you can do ai
describe
um you can do copy paste stuff one of
the common ways that people like to
uh log their food is using the barcode
scanner and we do support that there
have been
people today who have been who have you
know
sent us feedback saying like hey the
barcode scanner doesn't seem to be
working at the moment and so
basically what happened was
a lot of people
got the app and so like uh the barcode
scanner people were like yeah you can ba
we'll basically support up to like this
many folks and then a ton of people got
the app really quickly which is a really
nice problem to have and we had to get
them on the phone and be like hey dude
we need more barcode scans so if there's
an intermittent lapse you know
there we got notification of that
earlier today made a phone call it was
fixed i don't know if the people
commenting are referring to earlier in
the day or if it's happening again i
mean i i think there are
they're probably either asking about
that or asking about if they live
outside of the u.s yeah and that that is
the other thing i wanted to mention so
uh outside of the u.s you know the the
database that we use is uh you know is a
u.s database you know and so
people internationally have wondered you
know if the database doesn't cover
a lot of the foods that i commonly eat
uh you know what am i to do with that
and
there are options there right so uh of
course you can do custom food entry and
custom recipe entry within the app
um another option one of the things that
that's pretty cool is if you're
if you really like the app uh and the
guidance it gives in terms of adjusting
your calorie targets macro targets
things like that but you
have a data you know have a food logger
that works better in your country you
can actually link that up and so for
some of our international users they
might find it uh convenient
to uh use the the nutrition information
they're currently logging in a different
app and then sync that up so that the
name the the numbers will come in
via that syncing process um but then
enter into the app just like if they
were logging with the built-in logger so
uh do you have anything to add when it
comes to international food
stuff i mean really just to be
transparent that that is one of the
major weaknesses of the app right now
yeah um
we
absolutely want to expand international
database support and barcode support um
to be completely transparent about why
we haven't thus far is that uh
it's it's [ __ ] expensive to do it
right so there are some some uh free
open source databases that that have
some foods from some other countries
but the drawback there is that basically
if we were trying to do api calls to
those databases in addition to
nutritionx
it would
absolutely destroy load times for
searching for just about anything so it
would make uh it would make the app suck
worse for everyone and so the the clear
way forward to support that better um
would be so
nutritionx and some other
companies as well
allow for services where you can
basically download their database and
manage it yourself
and that would give us the ability to
maybe go to some of those free open
source databases and pull some of their
stuff add it to the database and so then
you're just making a call to a single
database or um
have a crowdsourcing system that
hopefully works a lot better than my fit
my fitness pals where um
not only would would users be able to
create their own foods and share with
everyone but also
there could be a system to basically
upvote down vote uh entries people make
or suggest corrections to them
um so anyway those are
things that are doable and things that
we
absolutely intend to do in the future
uh but getting to that point uh takes a
lot of money and so
we're gonna get there but it it wouldn't
have been feasible for that to be a
launch day addition to the app so um
so yeah that's hopefully that answers
that question yeah and you know when it
comes to databases there's always that
challenge of you know
database selection's hard right you have
to think of you know
coverage for different countries but you
also have to think of you know some of
the big um
criticisms of some logging apps
is that the database just contains a lot
of food entries that are very wrong you
know and so that's the one thing with
the database we use that we feel great
about is that you're not going to be
going in there and finding just
absolutely ridiculous yeah foods in
there so um yeah the whole time i've
been using it i think i found like
maybe four entries where i'm just like
ah
yeah
that one's a lemon
right i mean but it's not actually a
lemon like a bad entry yeah
yeah
um
but you know to our knowledge that we're
using the largest
rd verified food database that that's
available here so um you know it's
it's a it's a solid database but like
you said we're uh
gonna focus very intently on uh
expanding some of that international
coverage in the future
yes all right let's uh let's keep it
moving
um
let's see does the app support tracking
for marijuana consumption this actually
relates to to uh the previous answer we
don't manage the database yet so there
are uh some edibles that show up in the
nutritionx database we don't currently
have the ability to stop users from uh
from logging marijuana and marijuana
related products
uh but we'll get there that's that's a
key area for improvement as well
um we don't have the power to stop it
but we do have the power to email them
about it every day correct and boy have
we yes uh what is the best pasta shape
i'm a big bucatini guy
i have no idea what that is that's the
it's a long pasta and it's round and it
has a little hole in the middle
oh like uh like a macaroni and cheese no
but long
uh
but so
an entire bucatini noodle could fit
through the hole of a macaroni and
cheese whoa how do they make that
uh
that's crazy i'm pretty sure it's just
pushed through a bronze dye like most
shaped pasta but it has just kind of
like a little hole in the middle i'm not
entirely sure how they make bucatini
that's a good question
it is a good question anyway i'm a big
bucatini guy um
biggest celebrity crush
uh
my wife is famous in my heart and she is
my number one celebrity crush um
you know i i think i could argue that uh
my wife lindsay knuckles is a minor
celebrity um
she was given a credit in james clear's
book atomic habits which
was a number one new york times
bestseller for
ever maybe it still is i'm not totally
sure a bunch of [ __ ] people have read
that book which is good it's an
excellent book um
but if if you quantify celebrity status
in terms of
total number of eyeballs that have seen
someone's name
uh i'd say i'd say she's a um
low to mid-tier celebrity so well i'm
gonna trip you up on this without
without uh a shade of irony my wife
number one celebrity crush i'm gonna
trip you up on this so you said you know
it's about the number of people whose
eyes are getting i'm saying if you if
you define it as such right and she was
giving it credit right so like in the
first few pages that nobody really looks
at right
i think everyone
does look at them well
what about someone else in your family
who actually starred in the book
i do not have a crush on my dog but
oswald might be the biggest celebrity in
the family
that that is true
uh so yeah there was uh
a
per
a real person i was gonna say a
character but there was a person whose
story james recounted in the book and
the person wanted a pseudonym to be used
for him instead of his real name uh and
lindsay suggested oswald knuckles which
is my dog
and that's what made it to the final
version of the book so i love the fact
that oswald is in that book oh it's it's
excellent so yeah if you've read atomic
habits and
you read the story of uh i think
software developer from alabama named
oswald knuckles uh that is my dog's name
but that is not
his story he knows nothing about
software
uh who's your biggest celebrity crush
uh
nah pass
[Laughter]
my girlfriend is
a violent person
not a kind woman
so pass
fair enough
um
let's see what would it take for me to
get my beard down to nipple level a lot
of time uh i've gotten my beard
down to my chest before not nipple level
uh it just gets annoying after a while
though
um
okay difficult question from fabian day
when will the app work for countries uh
not near the us for example in new
zealand
uh to be clear it does
it does work there so yeah uh
the the drawbacks you'd have is poor
barcode support
um and and local branded products uh
probably wouldn't show up
um
so if you're someone who is primarily
interested or
who cares a lot about uh tracking
micronutrients
that actually doesn't matter at all
because the best micronutrient support
is for the common foods in the database
which
uh aren't the ones you'd pull up from
from barcode scanning yeah potato
stuff like that for example yeah um but
yeah so uh
i mean i would say
95 of the app works uh virtually
everywhere in the world right now um but
i i don't we don't have an eta for
expanded database and barcode support
but
it's it's a high priority once once we
make enough money to justify it we'll
get there and to pay off that fourth
home
that you mentioned earlier yes and that
as well
um
let's see
leonardo asks is being a landscape or
moderately active or very active lol
i'd say very active very active if
you're doing it right
um so i i used to do construction uh and
as kind of a job on the side some some
of the people i worked with uh also kind
of had like a handyman business on the
side
and we would sometimes get contracted
out to also help with uh
with landscapers like we kind of did a
little bit of everything
um
and i gotta say landscaping was
was some of the hardest work that i did
uh i would
if if landscaping is not very active i
would would not want to even dabble uh
with a job that was
uh here's a good one from mark what is
the latest cool gift you treated
yourself with
uh
well obviously on my road to
enlightenment i've
largely shed my attachment to material
objects
however
i was so impressed by the webcam that we
got for this
that i went and got one of my own
and so now i'm just like uh
trying to find ways to use it in a way
that that's not stupid you know i'm just
like oh man
you're gonna become a twitch streamer
pretty soon yeah pretty much i'm like
you know trying to line up a bunch of
interviews like surely someone wants to
see me on this webcam right
but no i'm stoked about that i'm really
happy with it what about you
uh
oh
i think this is a a treat yourself type
thing these shoes they're oh
they're nice sketchers slip-ons uh
memory foam soles yeah they
i mean
i think they were like 40 or 50 bucks
and therefore
about four times as expensive as
everything else i'm currently wearing
yeah um
so yeah i got these sketchers
maybe like three or four months ago and
that's uh
that's probably it
nice
um
i will say this if you're looking to
treat yourself to something
uh before the webcam i got i would say
uh
everyone should own a rice cooker it is
the single best uh kitchen appliance you
could possibly get i got i got a rice
cooker several months ago and it changed
my life so if you don't have one you
should treat yourself to that which uh
which brand of rice cooker did you get
the least expensive one at walmart
interesting
so
i forget the name of the brand okay is
there like a recall it's leaching heavy
metals into my no no no so um
i also have a very
old cheap rice rice cooker
and
multiple asian people have told me that
i should acquire a
they always say baby elephant brand rice
cooker uh the actual brand name is
zojirushi or yeah i assume that's how
you pronounce it i think it's japanese
so more or less phonetic um
yeah it has a cute little baby elephant
on it and apparently that is the
cadillac of rice cookers
nice
um
let's
i'm trying to find a tough app question
that that will make us squirm a little
bit oh
um
let's see
oh yeah so so here's a good one um also
about a feature we want to add that we
currently lack
let's see the kid sky says a small
feature that i missed from other diet
apps using macro factor is the quick add
feature where you log specific macros
and calories without creating permanent
custom foods any plans to add this yes
absolutely we have imminent plans to add
that that will
that will be coming out in a
uh
my brain's not working i want to say a
very soon release of the app uh but
that's not correct english yeah that's
not how sentence is yeah
a release of the app that is in close
temporal proximity to the present day
that's the most concise way to yeah
jesus christ my brain's [ __ ] broken
uh but yeah so um the app doesn't
currently have that i can tell you the
workaround that i currently use
um so i created custom foods for protein
fat and carbs so you know the the custom
food entry for protein it weighs one
gram it has zero grams of fat zero grams
of carbs one gram of protein four
calories oh that's smart yeah so i just
made custom macro entries as custom food
entries um so i just log those when i
want to quick add calories um so you can
just say i'm going to add you know 14
proteins
you know six carbs or whatever so um
that is a
i was going to say convenient workaround
it's certain it's a not inconvenient
work around currently yeah that you very
much can do and do and do pretty quickly
in the app
um but uh native robust support for
quick adding calories or macros to a
particular hour of the day um that is
going to be coming soon but you are
correct that we don't currently have
that
uh cool do you want to uh
talk about
batch cooking in terms of like quick
ways to do that like if you're doing
your meal prep
you know we can because i think some
people are going to be interested in
like you know basically
how you do it every week where you kind
of weigh out the whole thing and then
create your serving size and whatnot
yeah i mean
you pretty much described it uh i log
all of the foods uh
because people have been asking about
like recipes and cooking in bulk and
things like that yeah so i i cook in
bulk every week i make enough food in
one go to last me about 10 meals
people say that food is only safe in the
fridge for like
four to five days
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude i keep food
in the fridge for 10 days
that's not advice though don't take yeah
that's not advice that's a personal
anecdote but i've never gotten food
poisoning from it so whatever do with
that what you will uh but yeah i cook a
big batch of food um
most weeks every 10 days at most and
every five days at the least if i'm also
dipping into some of that stash for
dinner going into too many details
anyways uh yeah i just log all of the
ingredients and then
when i'm done i weigh out the dish so
you know
have the big cooking dish that that
whatever i
that i cooked whatever i just cooked in
uh and then i'll have some tupperware
i'll set the tupperware on my kitchen
scale and i'll just
ladle out my my bulk prepped casserole
or whatever it is into that and then i
have the weight and i record the weight
for the entire recipe in the app and
then i can log servings and grams just
just like i would log anything else
good stuff um
[Music]
try to see if there are any other uh
either challenging questions or uh
fireside chat off topic oh here here's a
good one as well
also from the kid sky
any plans to integrate step counts by
integrating data from apple's health app
um so yeah we we do already integrate
with apple health
currently we only pull
weight data from apple health so for
example if you have a smart scale and
you already just step on the scale the
scale logs the number to apple health or
some other smart scale app and then
apple health pulls data from that app we
can pull weight data from apple health
so you don't have to enter your weight
three different places on your phone
every day
um
but yeah since we have that integration
um
so so this this i think is important to
explain about how our
daily energy estimation calculation
works uh because people have been asking
about um
whether we have or will soon have a
garmin integration and we don't
and we will probably have one eventually
but it might not be particularly soon
and so that may seem like a big drawback
like hey uh this is what i'm using to
log my my activity like it's in my
garmin app uh will that [ __ ] up your
calculations and no it won't um so our
our algorithm is based purely on
uh changes in weight and logged
nutrition intake that's all you need
to be able to deterministically
uh get a good estimate of someone's
daily energy expenditure and once you
know someone's daily energy expenditure
you
can can then estimate pretty well how
much you need to increase or decrease
their daily caloric intake to get them
to gain or lose weight at their
uh desired weight so um
basically we're solving for
uh daily energy expenditure and so uh
pulling uh activity data
is unnecessary for the app to work well
however uh it could potentially work
better and i say potentially because we
don't we don't know this yet
but one of the things on the horizon is
to start
not yet using activity data or step data
but to start pulling activity data so
then we can analyze basically like we
can run models we can run tests to
determine
whether incorporating some of that
information can improve the accuracy and
precision of our estimates and our our
calorie targets that we give people
um
it works great now but that's one of
those things that i alluded to earlier
that might improve things a little bit
more so for example here's
uh is a situation where our algorithm
works well but maybe could work better
so we
we base our calculations on
um
on data that we're pulling from
up to three weeks old like we're not
uh we're exponentially weighting things
it's not just like a flat uh
flat moving average um so you know your
data from three weeks ago doesn't count
as much as your data today but we we are
incorporating uh relatively like a
relatively long tail of data um and that
helps us smooth things out so we're not
saying like oh hey you lost half a pound
less this week than you were supposed to
like we're dropping your calories by a
thousand calories a day or whatever um
so the the smoothing helps with that it
makes sure that we're we're not over
correcting for things
but on the flip side uh with any
algorithm like this you're trying to
balance
um
appropriately responding to signal while
being able to ignore noise and you're
trying to not over correct for things
and so you want to be reactive without
being overly reactive correct correct uh
and so a situation where our current
algorithms will work well but probably
could work better
is if you have a relatively large change
in your daily physical activity uh so
for example
if um
like i don't know if if you previously
had a super sedentary job and you get a
super active job or you previously had a
super active job and then you get an
office job something like that where
where you have or you know you go from
uh
being fairly sedentary outside of work
to
uh training for a half marathon or
something like that in a situation like
those where you have relatively large
shifts in
energy expenditure in a relatively short
period of time
the first week our our calorie
recommendations would still be
influenced by your previous
level of physical activity to some
degree so if your daily energy
expenditure increased very rapidly
for the first week you know let's say
your daily energy needs go up
legitimately by 500 calories per day the
first week we may only bump your calorie
targets up by
300 calories because
the the
shift in energy expenditure
um like we're trying to not overreact to
it but we end up reacting maybe a little
bit too slow
to an actual
uh relatively large relatively rapid
change uh and then the next week we we
might we would probably be fully up to
the 500 calorie increase that you needed
but basically you know most of the time
it's working well but then we're getting
uh
a slightly inappropriate estimate for
one week so that's you know that's not
bad app behavior it could certainly be
worse but it could be better and so
that's a situation where being able to
use activity data could help
um and like i said i don't know that for
sure but we could test it so if there
was a situation
where
it looks like say your weight is
decreasing faster than we think that it
then we would have thought it would have
given our current estimate of your daily
energy expenditure and if we see that
that coincides with a massive daily
increase in step count we could
potentially build some logic in that
says like okay in a situation like this
uh the increase in daily energy needs
that
would otherwise be slow
maybe let's make that a little bit
faster because what our
weight and nutrition-based algorithms
are telling us
is
it's the same thing that activity data
is telling us so instead of uh instead
of smoothing out this transition let's
maybe be a little bit more aggressive
with it um
so incorporating activity data could
potentially help in
in edge cases like that but like i said
we'll need to test it uh all of which is
to say um
currently i i don't think it's a
weakness that we uh
don't uh integrate with garmin and don't
pull activity data because the way it
currently works we don't need it uh but
that is something that we're going to
move towards in the future in an effort
to tweak and improve our algorithms yeah
all right do you think it might be time
to start uh wrapping up here
uh i i think we should do
two more fireside chat questions and one
more
uh challenging app question
all right cool
have you seen any alike
uh
someone alluded to ski season beginning
which i always like uh no further
commentary on it but you love to see it
uh i've officially once the leaves start
falling i start counting down the days
uh
for skiing to be a possibility again so
i appreciated that comment
do you have uh
do you have a weekend picked out to go
for your your first of the season
uh i do not
uh there's a question does saying i'm
from eastern kentucky university
improved the chances of my question
getting noticed
it probably does but we we have
definitely failed to give some of these
students extra credit so i i apologize
to the people whose questions we did not
answer um
let's see
a lot of people talking about their
favorite brands of rice cookers you'll
love to see that
oh man somebody said when will uh
trexler me
do a 10-day meditation retreat
apparently there's a center near
asheville that would be awfully
convenient and i love asheville very
nice that'd be good maybe i'll have to
cancel all my ski trips and do that
10-day retreat that'd be fun that would
be what would uh what would your
girlfriend think of that
uh it'd be fine anything to get me out
of the house you know
fair enough
um
let's see okay here's a good one uh any
plans to make a website front end for
macro factor
um yeah that's a good question we we
currently don't have desktop support
that is an area where we lag behind some
of our competitors
uh for example i know myfitnesspal has
desktop support pretty sure chronometer
does as well
so that's something we currently don't
have that we absolutely intend to add uh
and here's here's an unforced error
here's another thing that uh our app
could absolutely do better and that is
uh recipe planning so
um
yeah you can you can log foods ahead of
time but that's currently that could be
a better experience um so you know if
it's
if it's uh
10 p.m tonight and i already know what
i'm going to eat tomorrow and i want to
log it ahead of time i can do it but
like the smart smart history that i
raved about before
that's not going to work well for you
because you know if you're always
logging things at 10 pm at night [ __ ]
everything you eat is in your smart
history and functionally if everything's
in your smart history nothing's in your
smart history so that that could work
better um
and
uh
i mean just on a phone i think and this
could just be me i'm i'm not a huge
phone guy i'm i'm a big uh i'm a big
desktop guy uh but i think for for
planning meals ahead um
it it isn't ideal to have to do that on
a phone interface uh just because you're
dealing with less total real estate
so um
yeah two two big areas to improve is
adding desktop support and improving
uh meal planning and what we're calling
pre-logging um so like logging foods
ahead of time when you're planning meals
either for the next day or for the week
those are things that could be improved
and
where i was going with like not
necessarily liking planning ahead on my
phone i think that probably desktop
support will come first
followed later by
better uh
planning ahead type support just because
i think for a lot i think a lot of users
would find that more convenient to do on
their laptops or desktops uh so yeah um
those those are
uh things that we absolutely plan to add
in the
i would say middle future definitely not
far future but probably not super near
future um but yeah those are those are
uh definitely
areas where some of our competitors have
a leg up on us that we we absolutely
plan to uh improve pretty soon
you know i do have a
off-topic question here so
two people now have mentioned ohio state
football
uh one person asked if if they're gonna
win the big ten and i think one of the
things we probably need to clear up
is
what happened last weekend yeah um so
there there was a game with with oregon
you know that much we know
they're
i'm hearing a lot of stuff about
improprieties about the score
mm-hmm people are saying oregon one uh
but i'm hearing a lot of stuff otherwise
i'm hearing that there was weird stuff
going on with the scoreboard operation
and fortunately those scores don't get
certified for real until several months
from now so we should be able to appeal
it all the way up to the supreme court
yeah necessary so people are
provisionally tentatively yes oregon is
listed as the winner for that game but
there's still a lot to be figured out
there there were there were a lot of uh
mail-in points that came in
at weird times uh
i was i was gonna say that we needed to
stop counting scores but we were never
winning in the game
i've got the packet captures we're going
to blow this thing wide open
yeah there was no alteration of time
that could have uh helped us out there
unfortunately
it was a nasty game yeah oh well there's
always next week yeah but do you think
they'll win the big ten
i mean i haven't watched every team play
i think that until big 10 play starts
unless the rest of non-conference gets
really ugly i i think your your uh
bayesian prior has to be that ohio
state's gonna win
um
and i think that especially with a first
year starting quarterback i think that
he's gonna look better week by week um
i'm really excited about the run game
the defense looks out of sync but
um you know a lot of that i think
relates to
injuries and lack of depth in the
secondary so hopefully as the season
goes on if uh you know if the defense
gets healthier and gels as a unit i
think i think they have the talent to be
really nasty so
um yeah i think ohio state is poised to
to be a team
that's i mean already good uh
oregon has a lot of talent they they
played a tough game ohio state didn't
win uh but you know so already playing
uh
good games against a highly ranked
opponent this early in the season with a
team that still has so much room to
improve i think that that is a a
positive sign so i i still would pick
ohio state to win the big ten yeah
man someone asked if we would ever vlog
a day in the life of eric and greg
kidding me the the biggest waste of time
i
i was about to say no one would watch
that i'm going to amend that to say i
hope no one would watch it yeah a
complete waste of time um eric's eating
soup again that's old eric yeah that
would be it
um
so
why don't you look for another do you
want to look for another challenging one
or another uh
off topic one in the meantime i think
there's one important thing we haven't
mentioned it yet that ought to be
uh described and that is the fact that
the app does have three different modes
yes so yeah yeah this is a big one yeah
so i'm certain that a lot of people are
gonna want to use this app for its
tracking functionality because it is a
very slick
uh food tracking app it is very very
efficient and convenient but you know a
lot of people say well i like
controlling my own macros or
i want on the other side of the spectrum
to be totally guided through the process
here tell me how much of this and that
to eat so we understand that there's uh
a pretty
a pretty big spectrum there of people
who want some degree of control over
their uh macro targets or a great deal
of control so that's why we have three
modes so the coached mode is you know
very highly directed where you get uh
you know
calorie targets macro targets and so on
uh the manual mode is the other end of
the spectrum where you go in and you set
your own numbers so you know it's it's
very very self-directed and then there's
the collaborative mode that's kind of a
hybrid you know it's it's
more uh more guided than the manual mode
but less guided than the coached vote
yeah the way collaborative works is um
our algorithms will set a calorie budget
for the week basically to make sure
that the the
total weekly calorie targets you're
given will be appropriate for you to
reach and progress towards whatever
goals you have and beyond that literally
everything's up to you you can set your
protein however you want it
if you want one day where you completely
fast and another day where you eat 5000
calories you know be our guest you can
do that um so it it i would say
here's what i would say here's a hot
take so the way
it's not that hot of a take i oversold
this uh but basically the way the app
works is during onboarding you'll be
asked a series of questions and those
questions serve two purposes
one is to get an initial estimate of
your daily energy expenditure so that
that works the way just about anything
would so
you know we use um
the cunningham equation to estimate your
basal metabolic rate and then we have a
set of activity factors that we use um
to you know see
to estimate how much above basal
metabolic rate your daily energy needs
will be
so that's one of the things that those
questions help us get to and then the
other thing that they that they tackle
is setting up an initial coached style
macro program uh because basically
one of the things we don't want to
happen is for someone to log into the
app and just think that it's a food
logger and that there's no
uh that there's no coaching
functionality that the app won't make uh
macro or calorie adjustments for you so
you you basically go through the steps
of setting up a coach to macro plan
during onboarding and so you hit the
ground running you got that from day one
um
so here is my somewhat hot take just
about everyone listening
to to this if you're tuning in to watch
uh a webinar with eric and i at
9 30 pm on a weekday
uh
you probably
i would say there's in excess of an 80
chance that you
know enough about nutrition probably to
go with a collaborative plan where you
know we'll adjust calorie targets week
to week and then you have
uh incredible freedom to do with your
daily calorie and macro targets which
you please
so i would recommend one of the first
things you do after downloading the app
again not for everybody the coached mode
works great for most people but if you
enjoy having more flexibility as soon as
you get in the app you know play around
in the food logger a little bit we think
it's very slick but one of the first
things you should do uh is go to your
macro program and set yourself up with a
collaborative plan a lot of the
questions and
uh criticisms that we've got here on the
first day after release is like oh hey i
used some other app previously and it
gave me more flexibility for my macros
day to day
when are you going to add that to macro
factor and we're like
psych we did already it's already there
it's called the collaborative plan um so
yeah i think most people listening to
this collaborative plan is probably the
way to go so uh
or at minimum just just be aware that
that exists
yeah i think one of the things i would
encourage people to do
uh this app there's a lot more
beneath the surface than you might
expect in terms of functionality and
different modes and adjustments so i
would encourage people to
explore the app
because there's probably
several functions in there that you'll
like that you might not locate your
first time you open it up or your second
time you open it up so explore the app
uh press buttons get to know it and use
the knowledge base as well one of the
things that i think is really cool about
this app is that there's a pretty
extensive knowledge base that will grow
over time as well that talks about
uh you know
aspects of nutrition uh talks about
different guidelines nutrition related
but also talks about how to use the app
and get the most out of it um
and not just like uh be focused and
dedicated but literally how to use the
app what some of the features are and
how to access them so
there is so much depth to the app i
would encourage people to really dig
into it and explore it and ask us
questions if you have questions we'd be
happy to
direct you toward features that you
might not know existed and one of the
things i wanted to bring up when it
comes to flexibility is
because we have the timeline arrangement
for the food log
it does facilitate
uh time restricted feeding strategies if
you wish to go that route
you do have the opportunity to increase
or decrease calories on certain days if
you know some people like to have higher
calories on training days and things
like that you could do an intermittent
fasting type protocol where you have
fasting days identified um there is a
lot of stuff you could do there
um
so yeah a tremendous amount of
flexibility even for dietary strategies
that we aren't like our favorite thing
in the world to do
um you know we wanted to make sure it
was accessible and usable for those
things so even if you wanted to do like
a 5-2 diet time restricted feeding thing
it could be done uh you know
the uh the macro recommendations on the
coach mode really really go
you mentioned intermittent fasting yes
one of the cool things you can do on the
app that i had completely forgotten
about since you mentioned that because
uh
i don't do intermittent fasting so it
doesn't really matter to me that much uh
is you know if you uh
have a feeding window from like 12 p.m
to 8 p.m every day or something like
that and so those are the only times you
want to be able to see on your food log
you can go into your profile and instead
of seeing all 24 hours of your food log
and having a lot of uh white space you
could say like oh i only want my food
log to show up from
uh like show me by default the hours of
uh 12 p.m to
yeah 12 p.m to 8 p.m um
and and you can still log food outside
of those times if you uh
if you are eating outside of those times
but you know if you want to use that as
a little reminder to stick to the
intermittent fasting you're doing uh
that's a that's a cool little option on
our app that uh i don't think many other
people have so yeah they're like you
were saying there there are a lot of
like cool little toggles and options
like that um
that
even as one of the owners of the app i
forget about from time to time because
there is just
there are so many features in it already
yeah and
like i was saying so all different kinds
of feeding strategies with regard to
timing um the the macro plans for the
coached mode range all the way from
ketogenic to pretty high carb um you
know pretty low fat with the high carb
intake so
there really is a lot of flexibility to
accommodate as many dieting styles and
strategies as we could think to to
possibly cover basically everything that
we could
justify and not say like oh that's like
we don't have uh what was the one diet
everybody the grapefruit diet there's no
grapefruit diet mode um
built in yet
but uh yeah pretty much anything that
you would want to do that isn't just
tremendously contraindicated yeah that
there is a way to make it work in the
app
um i i think that's probably uh
a good place to wrap up well
probably the best place to to wrap up is
to talk about future trajectory of macro
factor very briefly um should be
um
pretty obvious based on the things we've
said in this episode but you know we are
the future trajectory for us involves
frequent feature updates based on user
feedback that's really important to us
uh consistently updating and improving
the algorithm to make sure that the app
gets better and better by the day
um and really uh
a big commitment to transparency you
know um we're always going to be
transparent about what the app can do
what it can't do who it's for who it's
not for so
that is what the future holds and we
hope that some of the people listening
and watching will be part of that future
and be part of our user base and the
good thing is now you could sign up for
a 14 day
free trial so no risk involved there and
again the the plans when you extrapolate
them out to their monthly costs they
range from 499 to 999 depending on
whether you go from the yearly uh to the
monthly
there's also the every six month payment
option so
if you want more information about the
app you can go to strongerbyscience.com
macro factor and that is where you'll
find it yeah uh so
just to reiterate um
two-week free trial if if your questions
are still unanswered uh download the app
you can use it two weeks for free
if you want to know like canado xyz and
we didn't get to your question uh you
can see for yourself
strongly strongly recommend also
either checking out the macro factor
facebook page
or or and or the macro factor subreddit
um
i am going to well me and
i assume all of us but uh i know for
sure me i'm going to be
very busy in there over the next few
days
uh and i mean on an ongoing basis but
there's going to be a big influx of
users that's going to be my [ __ ] life
or at least like the next week just
answering a ton of questions um
and uh yeah so if you want your
questions answered or you know if you
want to report a bug make a feature
request uh i'm very active both of those
places corey and rebecca are very active
both of those places um so if you get in
early here here's a little pitch to to
check it out now instead of waiting um
oftentimes uh
i mean basically always a new piece of
software will come out and it's it's a
bit of a blank canvas it it does what
it's supposed to do hopefully does it
well in this case definitely does it
well uh but then there are directions it
can grow and adapt
and we have
we have several uh
relatively major features that we
we want to get out relatively soon but
then from there it's it's kind of a
choose your own adventure there are
uh several directions that we think we
might want to take macro factor going
into the future
and hopefully eventually we can simply
go all of those directions but you know
one of them will be first and if you are
part of the macro factor community from
early on you will be able to help guide
that development to
make sure it goes from being
an excellent app for you to the perfect
app for you so uh
and as a path of development kind of
gets a little bit more set in stone
it will be a little bit harder to
have as much influence over some of the
directions we go
so there there is a clear incentive to
check it out uh and and get in the door
early
awesome so
that does it for this episode uh we want
to thank everyone for joining us we want
to thank everyone for their questions
uh apologies to those who asked
questions that we couldn't get to but as
greg mentioned we are not hard to locate
so if you have more questions let us
know we're always here to help out
whenever we can so thanks for joining us
and we'll see you next time